Вчитися - це класно!
Було би добре, якщо би ми всі це розуміли,
в той час, коли це треба.
Доброго дня. Ми з вами знову на уроці
географії в шостому класі.
Мене звати Чемерис Світлана.
Ми сьогодні з вами вивчаємо тему:
«Підземні води».
Ми з вами вже ознайомились з річками,
з озерами та льодовиками.
Сьогодні ми з вами продовжуємо
вивчати води суходолу,
і, зокрема, розглянемо підземні води.
Що таке підземні води?
Підземні води – води в товщі земної кори в
рідкому, твердому або газоподібному стані.
Для їх утворення потрібно дві умови:
1. Достатня кількість атмосферних опадів.
2. Здатність гірських порід пропускати
воду.
Сьогодні у нас є учень, пан Юрій.
Давайте з вами подумаємо, які атмосферні
опади можуть випадати на якійсь території.
- Дощі.
- Так, дощі правильно, а ще?
- Сніги.
- Так, сніги.
- Талі води, коли сніг тане і вся вода
потрапляє в ґрунт
і утворюються підземні води.
Правильно.
Тобто, якщо ми говоримо про
ті опади, які можуть випасти,
то дощові води одразу просочуються,
а сніг, наприклад, після танення.
Добре.
Тоді у нас залишилось інше питання:
які гірські породи пропускають воду
і з якою швидкістю?
Давайте з’ясуємо.
У нас є з вами невеличкий експеримент,
який я обіцяла вам минулого разу.
У нас тут є пісок, є глина, щебінь
і є граніт.
– Це, мабуть, не пропускає воду.
Так. Ми з вами маємо з’ясувати,
які з цих гірських порід пропускають
або не пропускають воду.
Ось є склянка води.
Давайте почнемо.
Тут я наливаю обережно,
оскільки у нас тут глина,
потрібно налити в середину
і почекати, чи вона пропустить воду.
Тепер щебінь, дивимось.
- Щебінь чудово пропускає.
Далі пісок, наливаємо
по самий верх і чекаємо.
Далі в нас залишився граніт.
- Глина, напевно, з усього найменше
пропускає? Вона в’язка стає.
- Так, правильно.
- Граніт взагалі не пропускає.
- Так.
От ми бачимо, що у нас там дві скляночки,
в одну буде туди стікати вода,
а інша, яка в середині ми будемо бачити,
пропускає він чи не пропускає воду.
Можемо так залишити,
тому що в піску зверху ще є вода.
З того, що ми вже побачили, одразу у нас
пропустив воду щебінь і пісок,
але щось пропустило воду швидко,
а якась порода повільніше.
Як ви думаєте, чому щебінь одразу,
швидко пропустив воду,
а пісок поступово пропускає і
капає поволі.
- Між камінчиками щебня багато місця,
вода швидко тече,
а пісок, він як губка, поглинає,
а потім випускає через себе.
Тому повільніше.
- Вірно.
Здатність гірських порід пропускати воду
швидше або повільніше
залежить від наявності в гірських породах
пор, проміжків, тріщин, правильно.
Чим більші пори, тим швидше пропускає
гірська порода воду.
Ми бачимо, що, наприклад,
між щебнем у нас велика відстань,
тому вода швидко просочилась.
Можемо ще повторити.
Пісок - тільки тут у нас вся водичка з
поверхні перейшла вже в колбочку.
А граніт і глина, якщо ми побачимо,
то з глини пролилась тільки та вода,
яку я пролила повз глину,
а граніт не пропустив,
також у нас в колбі майже немає води,
знов-таки та, яка по краях пролилась.
Тому робимо підсумок.
У нас є породи водотривкі і водопроникні.
Водопроникні породи легко пропускають воду
Ми з’ясували, що це пісок і щебінь,
в нашому випадку.
Водотривкі породи не пропускають
крізь себе воду.
Як залягають ці гірські породи і які,
залежно від залягання,
бувають підземні води?
Підземні води можуть залягати на різних
глибинах
і залежно від їх залягання, поділяються:
верховодка, далі у нас ідуть ґрунтові
води і міжпластові води.
Верховодка – це верхній непостійний
сезонний шар, який не утворює суцільного…
який не утворює суцільного…
- Наповнюється дощами, напевно.
Правильно.
Поповнюється атмосферними опадами
і не утворює суцільного горизонту,
і нерухомий, там немає течії.
Далі. Розглянемо ґрунтові води.
Вони залягають на першому водотривкому
горизонті.
Що це значить?
Дивіться, якщо ми говоримо про
ґрунтові води,
то ось у нас перший водотривкий горизонт,
це наші водотривкі породи, або глина,
або граніт.
На цьому водотривкому горизонті
знаходиться якась порода,
яка здатна пропустити воду.
Вона насичується водою, пори заповнюються
водою і утворюється водоносний шар.
Ті ґрунтові води, які знаходяться на
першому водотривкому горизонті
ми називаємо ґрунтовими водами.
- Це їх люди використовують в криницях,
причому там рівень міняється.
Він то вищий, то нижчий.
- Абсолютно правильно.
На ілюстрації на слайді ми бачимо, що
це води, які використовуються в криницях.
Це ґрунтові води, які мають течію
і напрям цієї течії буде залежати
від нахилу водотривких порід.
Як іде горизонт водотривких порід,
так і буде напрям течії.
Далі, це води, рівень яких змінюється
протягом року.
Якщо у нас опадів багато,
то рівень води підвищується.
Ми це в криницях чудово можемо бачити.
Наприклад, навесні, коли розтанув сніг,
рівень води поступово в криниці
буде підвищуватись.
Влітку, коли особливо посушливе літо,
то рівень води знижується…
- Відро об дно б’ється.
Так. З’являється наступне коло колодязя,
або навіть буває, що дійсно може
зовсім знизитись рівень ґрунтових вод.
Ґрунтові води забруднюються, тобто людина
може призвести до їх забруднення.
Про це ми трошки пізніше поговоримо.
Далі.
Також ґрунтові води, наприклад,
в ярах можуть виходити на поверхню
і утворювати джерела.
Воду ми можемо бачити не тільки
в криницях.
Далі ідемо з вами.
Наступний горизонт – це міжпластові води.
Міжпластові води – це води, що знаходяться
між двома водотривкими горизонтами.
Якщо ми повернемось з вами на слайд
зі схемою,
то бачимо перший водотривкий горизонт
і другий водотривкий горизонт,
між ними утворилися міжпластові води.
Що характерно для цього шару
ґрунтових вод?
По-перше, вони постійні, вони мають течію.
Але оскільки вони знаходяться
між двома водотривкими горизонтами,
то поповнюються вони дуже повільно.
І поповнюється в тих місцях,
бачимо на зображенні, в тих місцях,
де водоносний шар виходить на поверхню.
Тому що, ми побачили, що водотривкі
породи дуже повільно пропускають воду.
Далі, це води, які чистіші
від ґрунтових і вони мають течію.
Міжпластові води, які знаходяться
під тиском називають артезіанськими,
ось бачимо.
Коли бурять свердловину, то вони
можуть виходити фонтаном…
- Використовують в бюветах
- Правильно, їх використовують в бюветах.
Використовують в господарствах,
можуть бурити свердловини.
Вони чистіші і їх використовують, також,
як питну воду.
Ми дуже часто в магазинах бачимо,
напис «мінеральна вода», яка продається.
Це теж підземні води, ми їх
використовуємо, ми їх купуємо,
або їдемо туди, де є мінеральні води,
де вони природними джерелами
виходять на поверхню.
- Курорти.
- Правильно. Навколо таких джерел,
як правило, сформувалися курорти.
Не тільки в Україні.
Які ми знаємо курорти, які утворились на
базі мінеральних вод, за межами України?
- Французький Евіан, причому вони
натурально мінералізовані
- Правильно.
- Тобто, в воді ще є гази, крім кальцію,
магнію і всього іншого
- Так, правильно.
Наприклад, Карлові Вари.
Там ще води різної температури,
ще одна характеристика, термальні води.
Правильно.
Мінеральні води насичені різними солями
і мають лікувальні властивості.
Залежно від того, якими мінералами вони
насичені, вони бувають різних видів.
Бувають натрієві, магнієві,
варіантів багато,
і залежно від того є їхні лікувальні
властивості.
- Шлунково-кишковий тракт і так далі.
- Шлунково-кишковий тракт також.
Ми бачимо, що на території України у нас є
Трускавець, Моршин, Хмільник,
Миргород, Шаян - це теж курорти,
які сформувались на базі мінеральних вод.
Ми згадали з вами термальні води.
У термальних водах температура підземних
вод має бути вища 20 градусів.
Використовуються вони досить широко,
особливо в районах, де вони поширені - для
опалення будинків,
для отримання електроенергії -
геотермальної енергії, ми кажемо.
І геотермальні електростанції станції
будують.
Наприклад, в Ісландії є
геотермальна електростанція.
Також курорти.
У нас також є термальні води,
насичені різними мікроелементами,
тому ми бачимо приклад з нашої
сусідки Польщі.
В Україні також Закарпаття відоме
своїми термальними джерелами.
- А це правда, що вони під землею
нагріваються, ці води,
і виходять назовні біля вулканів?
Що вода нагрівається саме від…
- Так, від тепла землі.
Це в областях складчастості,
де є зони магматизму.
Дійсно, вони нагріваються теплом землі і
бувають досить різної температури.
Бувають термальні води і 60 градусів,
нагріваються до 60 градусів.
- Вони з запахами бувають.
Я був на термальних водах,
там неможливо взагалі знаходитись,
але люди сидять, гріються і дихають цим.
- Правильно. Це дуже добре,
наприклад, для суглобів, для шкіри.
Залежно від того, якими елементами
насичені ці води,
вони будуть мати різні лікувальні
властивості і різне спрямування.
Якщо продовжимо розмову про термальні
води,
то слід згадати ще північних мавпочок.
Вони проживають в Японії,
це північ Японії, там холодно.
Взимку ми бачимо у них такі шапочки
зі снігу,
але вони облюбували термальні джерела
і там проводять зиму.
Причому спочатку населення не знало
про лікувальні властивості цих джерел,
а потім, дивлячись на тварин,
населення також почало використовувати
термальні джерела, і воно увійшло
в культуру.
Такі термальні джерела називаються
в Японії «Онсен»
і відвідування їх стало традиційним
в культурі Японців.
Термальні джерела дуже поширенні в світі,
в районах вулканізму і магматизму.
- Тобто, ця вода нагрівається від магми,
що підходить вище до поверхні землі,
і вона постійно тепла, не дивлячись
на температуру повітря в регіоні.
- Абсолютно вірно. Вона нагрівається від
магми, яка близько підходить до поверхні.
- Це єдині мавпи в світі,
у яких немає артриту.
- Добре.
Підземні води, як всі води, і
поверхневі і підземні, великі трудівники.
Вони виконують велику роботу в
створенні і руйнуванні форм рельєфу.
Наприклад, ми знаємо, що під землею
є печери.
Коли є якийсь туристичний об’єкт і
запрошують в печеру,
всі залюбки туди йдуть, тому що
це завжди дуже цікаво.
Але ці печери створюють також підземні
води.
Інші більш небезпечні наслідки роботи
підземних вод – зсуви.
Коли насичені водою великі маси
гірських порід сповзають
і зсуваються по водотривких породах
під власною вагою,
під силою тяжіння вони зсуваються.
Тут невеличкий показано зсув, а бувають
зсуви з катастрофічними наслідками.
Тому варто пам’ятати, що не лише гарні
печери є наслідком роботи підземних вод.
Якщо повернутись до цієї краси,
то печери яким чином утворюються?
В легкорозчинних гірських породах
вода розчиняє породи,
наприклад, гіпс, вапняк, сіль
і утворюються величезні пустоти.
Наприклад, в печерах можуть бути
підземні ріки, підземні озера.
Такі форми рельєфу ми називаємо карстові.
Карст буває покривний і поверхневий.
Якщо ми розглянемо зображення, то бачимо,
що в печерах бувають і підземні ріки,
і підземні озера, але бувають дуже
гарні натічні форми,
яким у великих печерах навіть дають
власні імена.
Якщо розібратись в натічних формах,
то ми бачимо,
що є ті, які ростуть вниз та
називаються – сталактити.
Є ті, які ростуть вгору і вони
називаються – сталагміти.
Є суцільні, які називаються – сталагнати.
Утворюються ці натічні форми дуже
повільно,
тому що вони утворюються краплинка за
краплинкою
в яких розчинені гірські породи.
Ці гірські породи осідають, таким чином
нарощуються натічна форма.
Це дуже довгий процес.
Тому завжди в печерах, якщо бувають на
екскурсії,
там є відкрита ділянка для відвідування
Завжди попереджають: нічого не ламаємо,
нічого не зриваємо
і на пам’ять з собою не виносимо.
- Вже винесли все, якби могли.
- Так. Тому що це дуже повільний
процес утворення натічних форм.
Вченого, який досліджує печеру,
називають спелеолог.
В світі дуже багато печер.
В Україні також багато печер.
Найбільші печери ми знаємо - це Флінт
Мамонтова печера в Сполучених Штатах,
яка утворена в вапняках,
її протяжність 650 кілометрів.
Вона дуже відома всесвітньо.
Але при цьому мало хто знає, що в Україні
також є одна з найдовших печер,
але в іншій породі.
В гіпсових породах у нас є печера
Оптимістична на Тернопільщині
і вона також найдовша в світі,
але в іншій породі,
її довжина близько 210 кілометрів.
Але дослідження тривають, і довжина
щоразу збільшується.
В інших районах, де у нас поширені печери,
це - Крим.
Гірський Крим, там величезна кількість
печер і карстових форм рельєфу.
Багато з них відомі, туристичні печери.
Наприклад, Еміне-Баїр-Хасар,
Червона печера.
Вони дуже цікаві.
Там і вертикальні є печери, коли
утворюється до семи поверхів печери,
і горизонтальні.
Якщо у вас буде можливість, відвідайте
печеру, це дуже цікавий природний об’єкт.
Давайте перейдемо до
значення підземних вод.
В зв’язку з тим, що сьогодні вже було
сказано, Юрію, яке значення підземних вод?
Як ви думаєте?
- Вони живлять саму землю, не дають їй
засохнути.
Як ви сказали, дуже важливо для ґрунтових
вод значення діяльності людей.
Коли люди починають забруднювати води,
рано чи пізно вони обов’язково просочаться
туди, де артезіанські води
і тоді буде проблема глобальна.
Рано чи пізно люди залишаться без
тої води, яку можна пити.
- Так. Тобто, основне значення,
це питна вода, чиста питна вода.
Живлення річок, і можуть бути витоки
річок.
Ми знаємо, що в Карпатах беруть початок,
якраз із джерел українські річки -
притоки Дністра, притоки Дунаю.
Мінеральні води використовуються
з лікувальною метою.
Термальні води, ми сказали, що вони
використовуються для опалення будинків,
для виробництва електроенергії,
також для лікувальної мети.
Виходячи з такого великого значення
підземних вод,
варто звернути увагу на її охорону.
На жаль, підземні води забруднюються і
комунальними стоками,
і промисловими стоками.
Все це може просочуватись в ґрунтові води,
які активно використовує населення,
як джерело питної води.
Слід звертати увагу на очистку саме
комунальних і промислових стоків
і не допускати забруднення підземних вод.
- Можна я ще додам?
- Можна.
В мене є гарна історія про
Південно-Африканську Республіку,
де є проблема з водою.
Через низьку кількість опадів і через
велике забруднення, країна, багата країна,
Де є два океани, в якої є багато природних
ресурсів, для того щоб жити успішно,
у них проблема з водою.
В готелі, коли заходиш в душову кабіну,
є такий невеличкий пісочний годинник.
Його перевертаєш, і поки пісок сиплеться,
ти можеш помитися,
як пісок закінчиться, вода припиняється.
Потрібно буде чекати наступної подачі.
Це особливо стосується жінок, коли
потрібно помити голову з довгим волоссям.
Вода в крані, де ми чистимо зуби,
просто бризкає,
вона не тече - настільки люди економлять
воду.
Ми вдома з того часу, коли чистимо зуби
виключаємо воду, зайвий раз її не вмикаємо
розуміючи, що зараз, коли ми іноді
включимо кран, і вода тече,
в країнах, не так вже далеко від нас,
хоча ніби далеко, такі проблеми з водою.
Де просто іноді не можуть попити води,
тому що її немає, або вона брудна.
Це так важливо.
- Так, це важливо.
Взагалі, оскільки ми бачимо прямий зв’язок
між атмосферою, гідросферою і літосферою,
то варто згадати і приклад з Україною.
Коли на Поліссі, де велика кількість
випадає опадів,
де були великі площі боліт,
де близько підходять підземні води,
була програма в другій половині
ХХ століття, осушення боліт.
Для того, щоб підкреслити ще раз зв’язок
між цими оболонками,
то осушення боліт призвело до зниження
рівня ґрунтових вод.
І це теж стала проблема, тому що в
колодязях у людей рівень ґрунтових…
- Ганьба меліорації!
Різко знизилась.
Тому це дуже важливий зв’язок трьох
оболонок, які треба пам’ятати.
Проблема забруднення підземних
вод стічними водами
є дуже актуальною на сьогоднішній день.
Ми з вами вивчили основний матеріал,
який стосується підземних вод.
Давайте повторимо, що ми сьогодні вивчили.
Перше: що таке підземні води?
- Води, які знаходяться під землею,
так звані води верхівні, які знаходяться
зверху.
Залежить від кількості дощів і танення
снігів.
Потім нижній пласт, яким ми користуємось
для криниць і використовуємо в побуті.
Нижче - артезіанська вода,
міжпластова, яка є чистою і
дуже довго накопичується,
тому що між породами, які не пропускають
воду, водотривкі,
вони тримають цю воду в резервації.
- Так. Значить, підземні води – води
в товщі земної кори.
Ми говорили про два чинника - це пропускна
здатність гірських порід
і наявність атмосферних опадів.
Породи є водотривкі і водопроникні.
За умовами залягання, ви вже назвали, це
верховодка, ґрунтові та міжпластові води.
Ґрунтові води виходять на поверхню чим?
- Як вони виходять на поверхню?
- Де ми можемо побачити…
- В криницях, в ярах.
- В ярах чим вони виходять?
- Джерельними струмками.
Правильно, джерела і поповнюються вони?
Опадами.
- Атмосферними опадами.
Останнє питання.
Підземні води поповнюються, якщо про темп,
вони як поповнюються, швидко чи повільно?
- Поверхневі швидко, а ті підземні
дуже повільно.
Так. Особливо, якщо міжпластові,
то повільно. Їх потрібно охороняти.
- Берегти.
- Все правильно. Молодці.
Ми сьогодні засвоїли матеріал.
На цьому ми з вами вивчили тему:
«Підземні води»
ми з вами гарно попрацювали.
Я вам дякую за роботу.
Домашнє завдання.
Ви бачите підручники різних
авторів, з зазначеним параграфом
з теми: «Підземні води».
Прошу ще раз прочитати, ще раз звернути
увагу на нові терміни,
на значення підземних вод, на зв’язок
між оболонками.
Наступного разу ми з вами поговоримо про:
«Охорону вод суходолу. Якість питної води»
Дякую, до побачення.
- Дякую вам, дуже цікаво.
Я шкодую, що в мене в житті є прогуляні
уроки.
Ті моменти, коли можна було
використати для навчання, я десь прогуляв.
На жаль, так природа влаштовує нас, що ми
тоді, коли треба вчитися,
іноді ухиляємось від цього,
а коли хочеться, на це немає часу.
Тому, хочеться звернутися
до сьогоднішніх учнів.
У мене сьогодні був урок географії і я,
мандруючи світом, пригадував ці уроки.
Ніколи не міг собі подумати, що
вивчаючи якісь країни в школі,
я побуваю в цих країнах.
Зараз мені здається, що дуже
важливо знати і розуміти.
Чим краще вони будуть вчитися, тим краще
вони, потенційно, будуть заробляти грошей,
бачити географію на власні очі - річки,
ліси, озера, країни, які вони вивчали.
Це наглядний приклад того, що знання
дійсно дають людині можливості.
І це не просто слова.